hello everybody we just hit 40,000
subscribers that's an incredible number
that's that that's a big number that is
a huge number and um for her we hit it
way faster than I ever thought possible
and I wish I wish that I had something
more than just a reaction compilation to
celebrate it but because I've been so
busy with the November livestreams every
single weekend taken up I've got exams
next week on live at school leading up
to that I haven't had the time and I
wish I did but after this after this
next week should be over I should have a
lot more free time so thank you all so
much for helping me get to this
milestone thank you for those who have
been relentlessly sharing my videos I
know that there's been a select few
people that every time I release a new
video they shared num I can't tell you
how much I appreciated that because
that's what really drives my growth and
the growth of the channel and it's all
thanks to you guys and I know that I
don't ask for likes and favorites and
chairs every single video but when I did
on the reaction compilation and you guys
actually pulled through I I was I was so
happy to know that I thought that if I
asked people would be annoyed and you
know people don't like it I usually
don't like to ask for that things
because I feel like it it's obtrusive
and if you were gonna do it you're gonna
do it anyway but I know that if I do ask
some of you go the extra mile on top of
what you already doing it's nice to know
that you guys have my back like that I'm
still not gonna ask every single buddy
I'll probably only ask for you know very
very select videos so thank you guys for
doing that and thank you to yamimash i
if you haven't seen it already I just
recently did a collaboration with
yamimash over on his channel and on my
channel we did two separate amnesia
custom stories each one each Channel and
um it was great fun he's a great guy you
all should check him out I'll put his
link in the description below I'll put a
link of the video either under than
annotation or
in the description as well but he is a
really fun guy I like him but he's gonna
join me for drunk minecraft we're gonna
be recording this Sunday so look forward
to drunk minecraft at least three
episodes or two maybe with yamimash in
it and when I found out that he liked
minecraft I just hadn't I knew I had to
get him in there so there's got to be
lots of content to come and thank you
for the fans of yamimash who found me
entertaining enough to subscribe to my
channel it's great to have you here I'm
really happy ever since I did um I did
that did that collab the last few days
it kind of has been an explosion of
subscribers so I know that a lot of
people from his channel have come over
here I hope not to abandon yamimash
because he's a great guy too but thank
you so much for thinking that I'm worthy
of your time there will be a lot of
content to come
I'm going to dedicate myself after exams
are over of course dedicate myself to
really putting out the best video as I
can so thank you all so much and one
last thing my t-shirts are on sale this
is the last sale before Christmas so if
you were looking for getting a t-shirt
as a gift for someone else or for
yourself now is the time all everything
in the store is on sale if you use the
coupon code mark Xmas it's right here
mark Xmas all one word all caps ma RK
x-mas
so thank you so much click the link in
the description below for the
Spreadshirt store if you want a t-shirt
or a sweatshirt there's
t-shirts hoodies and iPhone cases if you
have an iPhone but that's
okay so um thank you again everybody so
much it's yeah I mean I never thought
I'd get to this point this quickly you
know I remember I was just looking back
in I threw some old messages someone
said three months ago congratulations on
8,000 and I went three months I've been
doing this for oh my god and so it was
really every single time I hit into my
so it kind of hits me that like what is
going on how am I doing this right and I
realized that it's not what I'm doing
what you guys are doing so it means so
much to know that you guys have been
there for me since the beginning since
I've been in this and I know I'm luckier
than a lot of youtubers out there you
know I was talking with young Nash to
try to get things in perspective and I'm
so grateful that people think that I'm
worthy of their time so thank you all
really honestly it truly thank you for
getting me to this point it it means not
an incredible amount to know that you
guys really support me so thank you
again and thank you all thank you for
joining me in there's gonna be a lot
more videos to come hopefully good stuff
so I think I'm gonna I think I'm going
to take some suggestions that people
would say and then asking me for a long
time to play so thank you again
just thanks for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video